Joe: From Burger King to Starbucks,
here are the highest-calorie
items and meals
in the US and the UK we
compared on the show.
This is Food Wars.
Harry: If you were to order
a Venti caramel Frappuccino
from a UK Starbucks, it
would contain 426 calories,
61.1 grams of sugar, and
117 milligrams of caffeine.
Joe: Harry, your Frappuccino's
looking a little sad there, buddy.
Looks like all your whipped cream melted.
So here's a pro tip from the USA.
470 calories, 74 carbs,
73 of which are sugar,
and 120 milligrams of caffeine.
Oh, yuck.
Yuck.
That's what that tastes like?
Harry: Well, in the UK, 6
inches of Meatball Marinara
comes in at 492 calories
Joe: In the US 6-inch meatball,
there's only 430 calories.
Yo.
Am I even in the shot
when I look at the camera?
Cameraman: Yeah, you are.
Harry: Well, in the UK, a
Crunchwrap has 578 calories.
But shockingly,
it has 60% of your daily
saturated fat allowance.
Joe: In the US, our hexagram is 530 calories
and is about 6 grams of fat
less than the one in the UK.
But, surprise to no one, ours has more sodium.
As is always the case, in the US,
you have to look at the beverages.
This right here is a large
Mountain Dew Baja Blast.
This is 30 ounces of a liquid
that is the most unnatural
green I've ever seen.
It glows in the dark.
It's so bright. When I close
my eyes, I can still see it,
like when you look at the sun.
This beverage has over 420 calories.
That is ridiculous.
I got to take a sip.
My body just took a screenshot.
That is ridiculous
that anyone drinks more
than an ounce of that
ever in their lives.
Apparently, people like drinking it.
It's very popular.
This has roughly 110 grams of sugar.
Ahem, for the people in
back: 110 grams of sugar!
That's way too much sugar
for a human being to have in a week.
It's an absurd amount of sugar.
Oh, God, it's like it's
horrible, yet I'm addicted to it.
Harry: For a large Whopper meal,
the Whopper itself is 627 calories.
A 180-gram serving of large
fries would be 437 calories,
and a large Coke would be 209 calories.
That brings the total of a
large Whopper meal in the UK
to 1,273 calories.
Joe: And in the US Burger King,
the Whopper meal comes in
at a hefty 1,600 calories.
Harry: If you are trying to
eat healthily at McDonald's,
it might actually be the drinks
that you have to look out for.
Joe: That's nothing, guys.
Our chocolate shake, 840 calories.
That's as many calories
as two cheeseburgers
and one hamburger.
If you were to walk into a UK McDonald's
and order yourself a large
Big Mac meal with a milkshake,
it would be around 1,400 calories.
Joe: And if you were to
get the large Big Mac meal
with a chocolate shake in America,
the total here is 1,870 calories.
Harry: If you were to walk into a UK KFC
and order a three-piece meal
and they gave you a
drum, a thigh, and a wing
with a large fries and a large Pepsi,
that would come to 1,155 calories.
Joe: Our large fry is 930 calories
and our large drink is 380,
and if you were to order a three-piece
with a large fry and a large drink in the US,
it would be roughly this many calories.
Harry: Let's compare large cheese pizzas
in the two countries.
This is what a UK large cheese looks like.
Joe: And this is what a large, properly cut
Domino's cheese pizza looks like in the US.
Harry: It's cut into 10 pieces,
and each slice contains 176 calories.
That means that in total,
the pizza in the UK is 1,760 calories.
Joe: Instead of 10, we got eight slices.
That means each slice
is roughly 280 calories,
which makes the whole
pizza 2,240 calories.
And according to the thing
that was written for me,
that is almost 480 calories
more than the UK large.
So a plain cheeseburger, regular fries,
and a chocolate shake
from Five Guys in the US
totals at 2,767 calories.
Yo, dog.
Also, I think this is about $70.
Harry: The same meal in the UK,
well, that comes to a
total of 2,769 calories.
Two calories more than in the US.
Well, in the UK,
that's a large stuffed-crust
pepperoni feast.
If it is 10 slices, each
slice is 292 calories,
bringing the total to 2,920.
One of these pizzas
contains more than double
your daily sodium allowance
and more than triple your
saturated fat allowance.
Joe: If you want to have
more calories in your pizza,
then you've got to go with
the most calorific pizza
on the Pizza Hut menu
and, thank you Connor,
that is of course the Meat Lovers.
This entire thing is 3,760 calories.
400% of your daily saturated fat.
400.
Harry: In the UK, it's a
sausage and pepperoni pizza.
Now, for an XXL version of this pizza,
each slice is 355 calories.
That brings the total to 4,260 calories.
Joe: Most calories pizza,
take one, Papa John's.
In the US, if you're
going for most calories,
it's a tie between the meats pizza
and the pepperoni, sausage,
and three-cheese pizza.
Each pizza is roughly
410 calories per slice,
and since it's 10 slices per pizza,
that is a whopping 4,100
calories per pizza.
Both these pizzas look like a nightmare.
I mean, there's a lot
of meat on this pizza,
especially this one right here.
This is exhausting just
looking at this thing.
So of course I'm going to take a bite.
No.